Javier Miley define que es ser de derecha, de izquierda,
liberal y libertario.
Mira, básicamente la mejor forma de entenderlo es
compararlo contra la derecha y la izquierda.
No digamos, para que la gente comprenda más fácilmente
quién sería alguien de derecha,
alguien que es un liberal helo económico,
o sea, no le importa con quién vos comercializás,
pero
no acepta que vos te metas en la cama con cualquiera.
La nueva izquierda, no la vieja izquierda,
la nueva izquierda,
es liberal,
sí en lo cultural,
porque te puedes meter con quién o quiénes se te ocurra
en la cama, pero es intervencionista en lo económico,
o sea, no te deja comercializar con quien vos quieras.
En el concepto del liberal libertario
estamos hablando del respeto y restricto
del proyecto de vida del prójimo
y como tal, vos, mientras que no le jodas la vida a nadie,
podés hacer lo que quiera,
comercializar con quien quieras,
meterte en la cama con quien o quienes quiera,
mientras que no jodas al otro,
no pasa nada.
Y además yo soy un liberal en lo institucional,
lo que pasa que soy minarquista de corto plazo
y obviamente de largo plazo.
Soy una narcocapitalista minarquista.
Solo seguridad y justicia en el estado.
Por una cuestión tecnológica, te diría.
Es decir, yo con veo al estado como el enemigo.
A mí cuando me dicen el estado presente me suena
al pedófilo en el jardín de infantes